so there's already hundreds
of refugees
housed here in qatar
we're getting quite close to that
deadline for international troops to
withdraw are you are we going to see
thousands arriving in the coming days
it's very difficult to assess the
situation from our perspective as a
state of qatar we try to focus on the
most vulnerable so female students for
example we've been focusing on that in
addition also to journalists and their
families
now very difficult to speak to the
west
but i think we need to wait and assess
the situation uh yet i should mention
that
we currently host actually in qatar
beyond the ones that are hosted the
evacuees that are hosted and in this
compound we're hosting uh around six
more thousand uh people in the military
bases
from our side i mean those are people
who are transiting right actually
from our side we're trying to provide
the basic needs that they need during
this short stay
medical services
logistics catering
etc etc now i should mention here that
honestly we didn't expect
this number
of babies kids pregnant women um and
we're trying to cope with the situation
everyone was talking about a timeline
that would last for weeks or months
but then overnight everyone was
surprised that
you know what happened has happened and
we need to deal with the situation is
qatar near capacity yet
that's a good question we're trying to
increase our capacity at the end of the
day
we're a small state that was not
necessarily equipped with such a
situation to give you an example this
compound was originally built for the
world cup so we're currently utilizing
some of the world cup facilities to
accommodate the uh evacuees
so um
yeah we're trying to increase the
capacity basically there's been a bit of
back and forth in terms of accusations
there was a suspension of american
flights coming in for around eight hours
the other day
and there was a bit of back and forth as
to whose fault that was what's been the
biggest impediment for you for qatar
in
bringing people out of afghanistan well
the situation is very surprising to all
of us so honestly at this point of time
we try to think productively and and
just think of solutions we're trying to
be solution oriented um
yet
some more planning
could have been
way more helpful to give an example the
qatar led process for evacuation is a
streamlined process where we get the
names we vet them we check that the
families are actually families
especially if there are kids involved
etc and then we carry out the process
once this vetting process happens we
communicate with our embassy there in
kabul and then our embassy the
ambassador himself and his own personnel
security they make sure to evacuate the
people in
shuttles that they uh secure
now due to
uh the limited capacity there for uh of
our embassy
they try to do them in batches uh
as well
you're also hosting the taliban this has
been their de facto office and
headquarters for many years now
do you believe them when they say that
women's rights would be respected and
that nothing will change it's very
difficult to speak on anyone's behalf at
the end of the day i only
represent myself in qatar yet we've been
mediating for years
and because of this mediation now many
countries including western countries
are able to
do many activities including evacuation
because we can discuss and negotiate and
talk
so it's very important to have
a mediator in the middle that is
considered impartial
by all parties to facilitate such
talks so
we still believe
that the role that qatar played in the
mediation is has been a constructive one
and we're willing to continue this role
especially that now more than ever we
receive more requests to actually
continue doing that and could we soon
see
you also mediating in talks between
countries who want dialogue with the
taliban
we're more than happy to do that yet the
golden rule is the willingness from all
parties so we don't jump in we just wait
to be invited how soon can we see those
talks happening
well i should say that
there are discussions
that
are more of
technical discussions to facilitate
things on the ground these are happening
as we speak as a matter of fact we keep
receiving guests from different
countries on missions that are not
always announced
to facilitate exactly that
yet if you're referring to
the broader political discussions
this might need some time
we receive messages from different
countries and we're conveying that
and we're hoping that at one point of
time we will be able to help the people
of afghanistan at the end of the day
this situation
should not continue